We're asked to rotate the line
segment negative 90 degrees
around the origin.
So this is our line segment.
We want to rotate it
around the origin.
So let's use our Rotate tool.
So let's define our
point of rotation.
So we're going to
rotate around the origin
so that's why I put it there.
And I'm going to rotate
it negative 90 degrees.
So I'm going to rotate
it in this direction.
So let's see if I
can pull this off.
So actually, let me
undo what I just did.
Let me get my Rotate
tool back here.
So negative 90 degrees.
So these arrows right
over here, right now
they're straddling the x-axis.
If I rotate negative 90
degrees, these arrows,
this double-headed, curvy
arrow should exactly
straddle the negative y-axis.
So let's make sure I do that.
So this is the negative y-axis.
There we go.
So I have rotated this line
segment negative 90 degrees
about the origin.
And now we've got to
answer some questions.
When a line segment is rotated,
the image created is a, well,
it's, of course, a line segment.
We know this is true because
the rotated image has two end
points.
The rotated image is the same
length as the original image.
We haven't changed
the length of this,
we just rotated it
around this dot.